who should you model after if you're in
your 60s it's not even a question it's
not even a question so the point is you
ought to go work out like yes RFK is not
eat junk food in your 60s like Peter
hotez's but to each his own I don't know
many 60 something year olds that look
like RFK I know a ton of six-year-olds
it looks sloppy like hotels yeah
actually believe it or not what what I
will tell you about uh of people who
take care of themselves there's there's
a lot of people that look at uh uh
hotels and say that's an irresponsible
way of living man you ain't going to be
doing anything good with yourself living
a long time living like that